ucsf chimera is an innovative molecular
graphics system with animation
capabilities
this series of tutorials will help you
to become proficient in using this
software
before beginning to work with chimera we
must first understand the macromolecule
data for a given entry on the protein
data bank
here we have pdb entry 1 hys the crystal
structure of a reverse transcriptase
enzyme from hiv
if you scroll down on the structure
summary page you'll find the
macromolecules section
here each chain in the structure is
given a letter code
we see here the first chain is given the
code c
however in the brackets we see that it
says
auth a this means that the author of the
study has labeled this chain as a
it's better to pay attention to the
labeling in these brackets because that
is the labeling that you will see in
chimera
similarly in the nucleic acid section
the nucleotide chains are given codes in
the same way
ucsf chimera is available for free
download for students and educators
following the link below you will come
to the chimera software home page
under download you will see the various
versions of the software listed choose
the one that is most applicable for your
device
upon opening ucsf chimera you will be
greeted with a black graphics window
with menus on the upper left hand corner
in the bottom right hand corner you can
use the lightning bolt icon to navigate
to the blue window which is the window
you will see upon each subsequent
opening
on the right hand side a list of
previously visualized files is shown
to open any of these files simply click
on it
to import a new structure from the pdb
into chimera go to file fetch by id
and type in the desired pdb identifier
chimera will then fetch the coordinates
and display the structure on screen
notice how some parts of the protein are
represented by ribbons and others the
ligands and specific residues are
represented by sticks
we'll explore representations further
later on
with the left mouse button pressed down
you can rotate the structure about the x
and y axes
the same motion done far away from the
structure will rotate it about the z
axis
with the right mouse button pressed down
you can zoom the structure in and out
and with the middle mouse button pressed
down you can translate the structure
across the screen
for users with a mouse that only has two
buttons such as a apple magic mouse
you can use the left mouse button and
the option key to achieve the same
translation
also holding down the shift key while
performing any of these operations makes
the structure 10 times less sensitive to
the operation
once you have found a view that you like
you can go to file
save image and give your image a
suitable title
if you would like a transparent
background remember to choose the file
type png
and a transparent background when
uploading to youtube the standard high
definition resolution is 1280 by 720
pixels to set these dimensions for your
image
uncheck this button here and type in
1280
by 720 as a side note images for print
publication require 300 pixels per inch
of high quality image content
so if you need to print an image that is
say
7 by 4 inches your dimensions that is
your resolution
would need to be 2100 by 1200 pixels
now with all these settings configured
you can save the image to a suitable
location on your computer
you can also save your session using
this option here which will retain all
of the current settings on your
structure
a saved session can be restored or
reopened using this option
finally when you are done working with
your structure
you can close the session or quit out of
the program entirely
one other important thing to understand
when you are learning to visualize
proteins is the difference between the
asymmetric unit and the biological
assembly
what i have here on screen is the pdb
structure 5 ire
which is the structure of the zika virus
capsid
now if you know anything about virus
structure you'll probably realize that
this doesn't look much like a virus
that's because this is the asymmetric
unit
to find the full biological assembly go
to favorites model panel and click
biological unit
now
the entire viral structure comes up and
if we zoom out we can see that it is
indeed a fully functional viral capsid
you can also see this distinction on the
entries structure summary page on
rcsb.org
by default the complete biological
assembly is shown here but upon clicking
one of these arrows we see the
asymmetric unit that we had when we
first rendered the structure in chimera